after a long drawn-out breakup it's
difficult being back on the singles
market you'll see where I'm going with
this and meeting new potentials trust me
I speak from experience but that is
exactly what the newly single britannia
is going to have to do but we're to move
on to well we've been swiping away and
there's a mr. big across the pond who
seems really interested said possible
new trading suitor is a rather fetching
continent with a young population six
out of the ten fastest-growing economies
in the world and sixty percent of the
world's arable land yes I am talking
about Africa and the most popular
continent to invest in right now just
ask China and with our diverse dietary
tastes being able to import produce from
Africa tariff-free feels like having
your jollof and Eaton rpm is certainly
ready to tuck in after hosting the
invest in Africa summit in London this
week I say this is the way to go we
remain as have to accept defeat
there's no point crying over spilt
brexit milk but if we are out of Europe
then I believe we should be in Africa
the right way as regular viewers of this
program will know I very rarely agree
with you okay but we're starting this
new year a new decade on a different
footing because on this I absolutely do
agree with you I think that people have
an outdated view in some regards of
Africa and its economies like you say
it's host to some of the world's
fastest-growing economies at the Murano
has been number one for the past two
years just to say it's got a huge and
very quickly growing tech sector and I
personally think that tech is the future
in lots of different ways but I do think
you have to be realistic in terms of
priorities because I think when we come
out of the EU I think the first priority
is obviously going to be trying to sort
something out with the EU and I
personally think next will calm probably
the u.s. next week China and then
possibly Africa because it is a fact
that actually when you look at the trade
the UK has been doing with Africa
it has been on the decline I think it
represents about two-and-a-half percent
of the UK's overall trade is with Africa
so as a brexit iere I do believe Forex
it presents exciting opportunities to
trade with rest of world but I think we
need to be realistic about the
priorities and what that looks like
can I bring in what our Prime Minister
had to say little issue and then whoever
wants to pick up after that let's have a
look but in the words of an old akan
proverb that I picked up in Ghana all
fingers are not the same
there's wisdom in these I can proverbs
all fingers are not the same in all
countries are not the same and the UK
boasts a breath and a depth of expertise
that simply cannot be matched by any
other nation because I saw what he did
say actually in the rest of the speech
was that Britain cannot expect to get
any special treatment and that it was
about redefining the relationship
between the United Kingdom and the rest
of Africa
so the point and the the sort of the
position he played was actually quite
impressive and I as you know don't often
say that but I have to say he was
brilliant
let me try to be positive here yes I
mean thank you for raising this topic
this has been a huge summit and I'm
really important yeah and I agree with
everything you said I think that it's
incredibly important to have a fair and
positive relationship with the African
continent I think that you're right in
the post brexit landscape we will need
to do these trade deals and I like
hearing the Prime Minister speaking with
a bit more humility towards the African
continent and King holding a can
probably a can probably he managed to
mispronounce I can but anyway the Spirit
is there that's great but a little bit
of reality check I think at the moment
first of all this used to be a colonial
relationship course and I see the ghosts
of that relationship everywhere even in
this summit so I've heard a lot about
British businesses getting into Africa
procurement supplying I haven't heard
any big African Businesses securing big
tenders in the UK trade should be two
ways to me how are we opening our doors
and inviting African businesses to work
and make money in the UK we cut our we
Bolton oh no we're not well I haven't
seen any emphasis on the - well are we
are we shutting them out and that can
point I want to make is that when
leaders in out on the African continent
of innovation tech and infrastructure
have been invited to the UK by globally
recognized
bodies like the WTO they have been
denied thesis by this government I mean
it's embarrassing story but the previous
Conservative government story after
story of people who hugely respects my
African continent frontrunners in their
field having the indignity of having
their visa applications sounds good okay
but I want to see I want to see the
substance I want to see Africans being
treated as people who have something
crucial to offer this country as equals
who are welcome here in the same way
that Britain is now being told it's
welcome on the African continent don't
you think I I totally understand your
point but don't you think that actually
breaks it does change things in terms of
the position that the UK is in now it's
a totally different landscape so the
people that you're talking about who
didn't get the reasons before and so on
it's a very different landscape now so
let's see what happens it was it was in
a climate where there's this hugely
toxic anti-immigration feeling
I don't think BRICS is cureless of that
oh no fair treatment I mean one of the
things I was interested in you know
throughout the referendum was about he
you protectionism and tariffs and the
kind of tariffs are getting posed on
sort of African arable farmers is there
scope here June for African farmers to
get a better deal well there has to be
100 percent and also the thing that's
interesting is actually if you look at
the amount of land that is available and
the fact that food shortages are going
to be a huge problem for us in the
future
Africa is the answer to that so whether
we like it or not we're going to have to
remove those tariffs because we need
them no it's looking you know the amount
of trade we do the country not Egypt
well it's a 150 million people we're
doing practically no trade there and it
just you know it's another example and
you know they've been positive now just
struck by everybody that you have to you
just got to be product if that's one of
my fears when the the pound slumped in
currency we all spoke about these export
opportunities and exports haven't really
risen so what allied sees is that all be
matched by actual business deals being
done I just like to point out a little
irony here that African continent is
really on the rise in part because of
all these intense efforts to achieve
greater regional integration regional
bodies
I don't trade because they recognize
that actually to be strong in the global
economy you need to be in a trade bloc
with your neighbors just saying what I
find most fascinating about this entire
debate is that June Sarpong the arch
remainer
aunty brexit cheerleader of labour I
just had this video last Johnson is
brilliant I've said I submitted the
speech was brilliant I quite like to
talk to Jude about some investment
opportunity on the pledge why likes and
retweets aren't always the key to
hashtag success
[Music]